their priorities are so off they're so
far off that they're automatically by
default damaging the very people they
govern and speaking of another one of
those people here is New York Governor
Kathy hokel and I cannot believe that
this woman I know I call her Kathy c
word usually I cannot believe that the
people of New York reelected her but
they did and they will now get what they
deserved she still this is this weekend
she still will not hire unvaxed health
care workers even right now with
everything we know take a look our
Health Care Systems seem in desperate
need of Staff right now we've had
ambulances waiting five hours at our
local emergency rooms to unload patients
the hospitals the nursing homes say
they're waiting for Doh guidance on
whether they can hire any of those
workers back what's the latest with that
it's a problem but I don't think the
answer is to make have someone who comes
in who's sick be exposed to someone who
can give them
Coronavirus
given covid-19 I don't know that that's
the right answer in fact I'm pretty sure
it's not so we're exploring our options
but I think everybody who goes into a
health care facility or nursing home
should have the assurance and their
family members should know that we have
taken all steps to protect the public
health and that includes making sure
those who come in contact with him at
their time of most vulnerability when
they are sick or elderly will not pass
on the virus we lost 34 New Yorkers
yesterday
we have 4 000 Active cases this has not
gone away as much as we wish it would
couldn't there be other safety
precautions masking other other
mechanisms in order to allow some of
them back in I mean we're at crisis
level here in our hospitals I I truly
understand the challenge and the balance
and these are never easy decisions but I
cannot put people into Harm's Way
because when you go into a healthcare
facility you expect that you're not
going to come out sicker than you went
in all right guys we're getting
demonetized that Botox has no idea
what she's saying okay the fact is that
if you get the vaccine you can still get
and transmit covid more people who have
gotten the vaccine have died of Kobe
than people who have not and if the
vaccine worked and someone walked in who
was unvaccinated then the sick person
the other person would not get sick
right it's also extraordinarily stupid
but they keep going they cannot that
Botox that's a good line we're
gonna we gotta use that one again
um it's just endless with these people
someone please if you are in New York
and you're sane and I know it's a thin
little sliver of people that we could
say that about I have a couple family
members that are pretty decent but like
someone sue the hell out of her the idea
that the governor is saying we will not
hire unvaxed people while they're having
these shortages while uh ambulances are
backed up and emergency rooms are
overflowing and everything else it's
like if any of that is true and that's
what you're doing somebody Sue this
woman put her on the penal colony of
urapente
that's a Star Trek reference I think it
might be the first one I've ever made on
this show
[Music]